tu as lu aujourd'hui de nouvelles
énigmes comme tous les jours durant 32
jours mais avant la nouvelle énigme la
réponse de l'énigme d'hier si vous
l'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier commencer
par regarder la vidéo puisque la réponse
vous la donne maintenant pourquoi ce
businessman at-il licencier son veilleur
de nuit
et bien simplement parce que son
veilleur de nuit a commis une faute il a
dormi durant la nuit un meilleur de nuit
ça doit rester éveillé surveiller son
travail n'est pas de dormir durant la
nuit et comme il a rêvé que l'avion
s'écraser le fait d'avoir rêvé ça ça
voulait dire qu'il dormait comme il
dormait c'était une faute
professionnelle et c'est pour ça que
businessman la licencier oui c'est
injuste car il lui a sauvé la vie je
suis assez d'accord avec vous et c'est
pour ça qu'on va vite passer l'énigme du
jour
énigme 28 un petit peu littéraire déjà
c'est un indice là que je vous donne qu
est-ce qui commence la nuit qui finit le
matin et qu'on trouve deux fois dans
l'année je ne dirai rien de plus vous
avez 24 heures pour trouver la solution
qui est tout à fait logique et que vous
allez pouvoir trouver j'en suis sûr on
vous l'avait trouvée mettez un pouce en
l'air qu'on puisse voir le nombre de
personnes qui ont trouvé par rapport au
nombre de vues ne donnait pas la réponse
dans les commentaires c'est beaucoup
mieux pour que les autres puissent
chercher et si ça vous tente vous pouvez
aussi partager cette vidéo pour propager
un petit peu cette énigme et ce jeux des
énigmes de l'été en tout cas le mental
blog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
17h cha
ouais